in life you know you've i feel like for
me i noticed in my life there's like a
i found like an uh like i in the past
two years i've started to make a little
bit of money in my life and i never had
any money
yeah and money was always and i think in
a lot of people's lives
it's always it's a goal it's a motivator
it's a
and i don't know if it was my motivator
i think some type of a success was made
my motivator and i've achieved some
success
hell yeah but i felt like it's not as
there really isn't it's not as joyous as
you would
it doesn't pay off really exactly like
you've kind of
i for me it hasn't paid off exactly like
i felt like i felt like it would like
i thought it would yes it's not what you
thought it would be right let me tell
you so i'm 16 years i'm 56
you're 40 right yeah so here's here if
happiness is hard work brother
and it's it's hard to make it it's five
times harder to hold on to it that's
number one thing with money okay it's
five times harder to hold on to it
number two money doesn't bring you
happiness you want to be happy
you got to watch your sugar you got to
drink a lot of water you got to exercise
in the morning
you got to keep your house in order keep
your life in order and you want to
and i have to hang around people that i
aspire to be like
or want to be like because it rubs off
on me you got to have a presence of
discipline you got to have a presence of
balance
and and you got to have a little bit of
fun and you got to forgive yourself for
being human
when you over season your steak which we
happen to do once in a while as human
beings
and you can take that any way you want
to take it and forgive yourself so you
can get back on
the track of happiness and happiness is
hard work man
um it is it is it is i'm a i'm a i'm
obviously a billionaire right
and uh uh but you know you can have
you can have 10 cars and and 10 boats
and 10 houses
and you can you can you can eat yourself
three chocolate cakes and six big macs
and six jimmy john subs
and you're gonna feel like [ __ ] yeah
okay and it's gonna be horrible and
you're gonna be
one horrible rich [ __ ] okay and
so
really happiness is hard work so and
genuine genuine happiness i mean real
not baloney [ __ ] you know right
being party that's fine but
real contentment happiness man it's hard
work and it takes work every single day
to do that and when you do it you know
when you do it every day or have a
presence of it
and then you have better weeks and then
you have better months and you have
better quarters and then you have better
years you know
i wish i would have known this 10 years
ago i'm learning this now
since i don't have all that the pressure
of jimmy john's so i'm learning this
stuff
now and this is for me it's i don't know
what's for you but this
this is the wine i like to drink i'm not
going to tell you what kind of wine you
like to drink but this is
you know i had a wine class one time i
paid 200 he says okay you're ready
for the class good wine is wine you like
great class over let's drink wow
so i'm like thanks man yeah thank you
what's all that [ __ ] they're doing in
the restaurant he says that's all
[ __ ] they're making all that stuff
up
because i felt so stupid with wine right
now i own a couple wineries and we do
very well
but that's besides the point so you know
it's just whatever it is to you but for
what i found is
you know i've been rich for a long time
and uh in my in my world
uh rich for a long time and and uh i
made my first million dollars in 93
and had no debt you know so having no
debt is huge
huge i didn't know how to get it i
didn't know how to fill out the
paperwork well it's funny your dad said
that you know
yeah yeah and those bankruptcies scared
me and i was poor and i didn't ever want
to be poor again
and uh so i was a real saver and still
i'm very conservative i only invest in
things that i totally
understand you know or a person that i
totally understand i i really
tend to bet the jockey not the horse
interesting man
yeah so that's the list people the list
is if you want to uh
if you want to have happiness in your
life
i feel like you started off by making a
list of the things you needed in your
kitchen
and i feel like you kind of ended up by
giving us a list
of your experience of the things that we
need if we want to
you know have some sort of happiness you
know um is that your is that
do you feel like that's where your a lot
of your motivation is spent now kind of
these days like
finding uh just feeling good finding
some happiness 100
i think contentment theo i think that um
you know um private planes are
convenient but you can be measurable in
a private plane
you know all those all those perceived
you know kardashian amenities right or
whatever hollywood amenities all those
things are great
but but to feel good you got to feel
good and and it's hard work to feel good
and so
i'm filling in a lot of a lot of gaps
that i that i wasn't able to do because
i was fighting the battle for 36 years
and i was just overwhelmed at the end it
was just so big and so
i was i was like drinking through a fire
hose and now you know really being
addressed my weight my health
and really every single day through this
thanks this this hunting season and
thanksgiving and christmas
and and really trying to balance myself
man uh i've done a better job this year
than i've ever done in my life like this
is this is my
the best life that i've ever lived and
i'm in a great direction and i think a
year from now
if we had a podcast i think you'll see
me 20 or 30 pounds lighter and
and um and it's just what i'm doing
right now and it feels good yeah it
feels good to sleep good
it feels good man it feels really shitty
when i drink a bottle or two of tequila
which i did last week with uh
with bobby and and uh and clint boyer we
went hunting deer in texas and we drank
a lot of tequila man and
and man i paid the price for three to
three days i mean hangovers at my age
are a week now it's almost not worth it
yeah oh hang over
your stock will dip you know you know
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering
how could i be so far from my
[Music]
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
blown